hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the keynote presentation using
new technology to control healthcare
associated disease I am Bob Woodard of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's webcast is
represented by lab routes comm the
leading social media site for science
professionals and sponsored by roche
diagnostics as a left of a global leader
in health care roche diagnostics offers
a broad portfolio of tools that help
healthcare providers in the early
detection prevention diagnosis and
treatment of diseases in molecular
diagnostics we are driven by a vision of
working with laboratories like yours to
improve the medical value you offer in
microbiology infectious disease oncology
and genomics we continue to meet unmet
needs through our investment and
research innovation and scientific
excellence with the goal of supporting
your important role in improving
patients lives before we start there are
a few instructions we want to hear from
you during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are welcome to you
submit your questions by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window and typing in
your comments and questions we're trying
to get to as many as we can and we'll
follow up but we don't have time today
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide if you
have technical difficulties hearing or
seeing this presentation let us know by
clicking on the support button on the
top right or use the Q&A button and
we'll do our best to help solve the
issues now let's get to today's
presenter dr. Lance Peterson dr.
Peterson is the director of microbiology
and infectious disease research vice
chair of pathology for research and
epidemiologist at northshore university
health system in Evanston Illinois he is
also a clinical professor at the
Pritzker School of Medicine at the
University of Chicago and a staff member
in the clinical microbiology and
infectious disease divisions
at evanston hospital dr. Petersen
received his MD degree from the
University of Minnesota and is certified
in internal medicine infectious diseases
and medical microbiology dr. Peterson's
research interests have included the
study of infections and the extremities
of diabetic patients investigations
antimicrobial agents and models that
simulate closed space neutropenic
infections and the epidemiology of
nozzle chemical pathogens the
development and evaluation of molecular
diagnostic testing major activity of new
antimicrobial compounds against bacteria
and fungi and the study of molecular
mechanisms for the resistance of
staphylococci and pneumococci the new
full floral-print alone antimicrobial
agents current research activities focus
on using molecular testing methods to
enhance infection control activities
understanding the regulation of
antimicrobial agent resistance in
steffelow [ __ ] i and until bacteria ACA
designing novel strategies for the
treatment of infections due to distant
bacterial testing innovation is to
reduce catheter-related by the stream
infections and developing new diagnostic
tests for rapidly detecting antibiotic
resistant bacterial pathogens he has
only seven over 700 publications
presentations and is recognized in the
21st century editions of Arkady who
masood's please join me in welcoming dr.
Peterson today's event I'll now turn the
presentation over to him thank above and
hello everyone with the rapid event of
new technologies person one of the
issues were all faced with is bringing
these into our hospitals and challenges
arise from do they help the patient and
are they affordable air they cost
effective and what I'd like to talk
about in my presentation today is using
two key example organisms because they
really have different models for both
their
benefit and their cost effectiveness and
we'll get started with the with the
presentation these are my potential
conflicts of interests our laboratory
works with both industry and government
in developing new technologies and
assessing their outcomes so what I'd
like to cover today is to review the
problem of methicillin-resistant Staph
aureus or Mirza and clostridium
difficile infections specifically in the
acute care hospital setting also
discussed the impact of infection
control management on these infections
and increasing the benefits to the
patient and decreasing health care costs
and finally discuss a little bit about
what you can do at your own Hospital to
really determine our success assess if
you have a problem and some potential
interventions that you can implement if
you find that you do need to enhance
your activities there are several global
issues and infectious diseases they're
listed on this the top two mrs a
equestrian difficile our work i'll cover
today the first thing to remember that
is that mrs a infection is a human
problem if it can cause severe disease
this is a young woman from texas who had
a very severe facial infection with mrs
a and she's posted that youtube video
you can look on the on the link that's
on the slide here and she will tell you
her story which i think is very honest
and open that she's shared it with all
of us one of the one of the continuing
questions is should we continue to care
about mrs a as a controlled isn't it
controlled the state of illinois
publishes on a public website report
card on how we're doing and this is from
the most recent report card from data
through 2012 and the tall bars there
look at what's happening as far as I'm
RSA infections occurring in hospitals
across the state through through 2012
and you can see from two thousand nine
ten and eleven it looked like the rates
were going down but then 2012 the rates
were going up I've plotted our North
Shore rates on the lower shorter bars
just to show that it is possible to
dramatically reduce mrs a infections in
a health care system with appropriate
approaches and you'll see the same thing
in europe so this is data from the
european website in the european union
published in from from 2009 data and
we'll look at the next slide and you'll
see that some of the countries have
gotten better and some have gotten worse
I do think that in reading the
literature it will be it will be
somewhat heterogeneous but clearly
there's a lot to do and here's the 2012
data from Europe again showing some
countries have improved their situation
regarding mrs a and some have not so how
does one become infected what's the risk
of mrs a infection and then what really
leads to it what what perhaps can be
useful in prevention this is a slide
from a can work that was done in our
facility looking at almost 200,000
patients who had surveillance testing
done and the three groups represent
patients that were pcr positive as well
as culture positive in the nose for
group 1 group 2 or pcr positive only and
culture negative for mrs a and the group
3 were both pcr and culture negative for
mrs a and this looks at the mrs a
infections that occurred in these groups
over one year and you can see that for
those that were both TCR and culture
positive their rate of infection was
eight percent more than 10 times higher
than for those patients that were
negative the group two patients that
were pcr positive and culture negative
is intermediate
it and what we found in looking at this
is that some of the PCR positive culture
negative in the nose our culture
positive else or such as in the throat
or even the rectum so this does
represent some patients that are
carriers of mrs a but don't have to be
culture positive in their nose and the
takeaway from this is that the greatest
risk for mrs a infection is becoming
colonized with this organism so when we
look at colonization want us want to
prevent it there's been some very
interesting work suggesting on how mrs a
is spread throughout a health care
system and whole genome sequencing has
been used as one of the novel
investigations and this looks at a 10
month study and a neonatal intensive
care unit they started active
surveillance after they had for
infections and typically when you have
in phantom infection you'll have eight
to ten additionally colonized
individuals in the nursing unit and they
compared to several different typing
systems whole genome sequencing very
common one with common ones like
postville gel electrophoresis by typing
and they found that whole genome
sequencing was actually the best in
defining clusters they had five indian
infants and two clusters and ten in the
cases were unrelated and whole genome
sequencing suggested two different ways
that this transmission was happening one
was what it was when the infants were
close to each other suggested healthcare
workers but also suggested that there
was repeat introduction of mrs a strains
which might suggest coming in from the
parents this is often difficult to talk
to parents about because they don't we
don't want to make them feel guilty if
really they have nothing to do with mrs
a showing up or occurring in their
babies and one of the questions coming
out of this was there any immediate
benefit of the whole genome sequencing
over pulsed-field gel electrophoresis
and the reason for the question is whole
genome sequencing is a lot more
expensive
impulse field gel electrophoresis
another interesting article that looked
at that looked at epidemiology and in a
different way is looking at what's
called close proximity interactions and
at at spread of mrs a an entire facility
and what what they did was using health
care workers and patients and they were
both cultured weekly but they also have
the health care workers wearing wireless
sensors this is becoming very common on
nursing units and they measure their
location every 30 seconds they found
during this this transmission
surveillance study in a nursing home
there 173 transmission events and they
look they did find carnality what was
interesting when they look at the whole
the whole nursing home not just to give
them unit ninety-eight percent of the
new colonization events had a close
proximity intervention pathway
suggesting that actually spread was
being done by healthcare workers and
there's an example of this on the next
on this scrap of the paper and what is
what you're looking at here the diamonds
represent patients the triangles health
care workers and then the different
colors inside each of them are a given
clone or non colonized patients and and
if you trace that the health care
movement around you can see that health
care workers are very efficient at
picking up mrs a from colonized patients
and even transiently colonizing other
healthcare workers and then spreading
clones throughout an entire health care
hospital or this happen to be a nursing
home so i think when we look at the
epidemiology we need to look beyond just
one nursing unit and look at the whole
the whole facility in order to really
come up with clear ideas as to what's
causing spread and again keeping in mind
that spread is what we want to avoid
because that seems to be in the
literature supports in many many studies
the best way of preventing
disease so there are there have been
several guidelines published over the
years and what to do with for control of
mrs a this is the latest one from the
Society for healthcare epidemiologist
for America or shea and you can see that
the first thing we're all supposed to do
is determine if we've effectively
controlled mrs a and i'll talk more
about that later but if we haven't
there's some special approaches that can
be considered and the two main ones are
conducted active surveillance testing or
AST for mrs a colonization and then make
sure that the compliance is being
followed and then implement
decolonization is the second option
targeted therapy for those that are
positive or universal decolonization
among high-risk patients so these are
just two ideas of things to try and then
again monitor outcomes to make sure
you're having an impact and this is what
we'll talk about next so this was our
mrs a screening program that we started
august first of two thousand five so we
just passed our ten-year anniversary and
the intervention was to do admissions
great active surveillance testing on
admission and the goal was to assure the
new admissions that we were doing our
best of it they would not get mrs a if
they didn't already have it we had a
high threshold for compliance we made
the ordering very easy a single a single
click in the electronic medical record
for the mrs a admission screen and then
those that were positive were put into
contact precautions and initially
decolonized we subsequently quick
decolonization because we found the
contact precautions alone are
satisfactory for for stopping
transmission and then for those that
were decolonized we made it easy again
just a single order to or single click
to order the package of nasal me pearson
twice a day for five days along with
chlorhexidine bathing and that was given
on day 13 and five and this is this
program actually achieved a very
this award for our health care
organization the Eisenberg reward excuse
me so these are our results and the fire
left bar is the baseline data there are
mrs a disease rates in the year before
we started the second from the left
between the two arrows we actually did
the program first in the intensive care
units at our three hospitals and that
had some reduction in disease but it was
not statistically significant with only
saw statistically significant reduction
in disease once we started doing all
nursing units and very quickly you saw
more than a sixty-five percent reduction
in infection which is typical for a
successful infection control
intervention one thing keep in mind is
that if you found something that works
with infection control usually you'll
see a benefit very quickly and this
continued on over the next several years
and you can see that we've had a
sustained more than seventy percent
reduction in mrs a disease during
hospitalization and we even count 30
days after discharge so we're using a
very liberal definition of mrs a disease
and in our four hospitals now we range
from 2 to 3 bloodstream infections for
all four hospitals combined per year so
very very low rates of mrs a clinical
infection so we'll question to ask and
when we're doing when they do things in
person we often discuss this but these
are these are different different
approaches to active surveillance or not
doing active surveillance that are used
throughout the united states most
hospitals in the united states now do
some active surveillance testing many of
them do it in the intensive care units
and many states have mandated that to be
done but even if you're doing it in here
intensive care unit it's important to
monitor the outcome and make sure that
you're having the m
that you're desiring this is the data
from the Veterans Administration in the
united states with about 160 hospitals
throughout the country and they started
about a year and a half after we did so
they started in 2007 and they're doing
active surveillance testing on all
hospital admissions and actually also on
all transfers and all discharges within
their hospitals and you can see what's
happened here is they're continuing to
see more and more nursing units where
they go for an entire month with no Mrs
a infections and that's what this plot
is and you can see that they've gone at
the start of their program from about
fifty percent of their nursing units to
in the next by 2010 to almost seventy
percent of the nursing units without an
MRA infection in a given month and this
is actually very very dramatic for a
health care system that deals
increasingly with older patients and
with patients with with disabilities so
this this has been a very very positive
thing for our veterans administration
this is another more recent publication
of theirs from 2013 and 2011 looking at
sustained transmission and disease
reduction in 153 of their hospitals and
right now they're generating over a
million patients and three million
patient days worth of data per year they
still have relatively high admission
prevalence of fifteen percent which is
nearly three times what ours is their
transmission rates very low two per
thousand patient days and they have had
significant disease reduction throughout
the system as shown on this slide the
upper diamonds are their intensive care
unit patient clinical disease with mrs a
and the squares are there nine ICU and
you can see that that I put in the line
for North Shore the
and we are sharing very similar outcome
results and their disease continues to
be low as as does ours I've also
highlighted the disease rates in the
Netherlands which is a country that is
as an entire nation has taken that mrs a
and driven the rates even lower so that
so that the wider you can have your
impact or the wire you can have your
intervention it appears from the
published data the better your overall
impact is and this is from a blog that
was taken from the new york times in
january of this year of some very
interesting comments the writer was
saying that the Centers for Disease
Control had announced the United States
was making modest progress but they the
writer said progress is good modest is
not and they go on to highlight that
hospital acquired infections is killing
more people per year than car accidents
and breast cancer combined and go on to
highlight the good job the VA has done
and I think I think this is a very good
model for us as a national health care
system that you can have a major impact
on mrs a with a well planned and
monitored program so the next question
is come has come up because Universal
decolonization has also been introduces
another method for reducing healthcare
associated infections and been also used
for mrs a and this is a summary that my
partner becky smith and i put together
in medscape and published two years ago
comparing the VA data you can see that
if you look at the final outcome the VA
has actually three to five fold lower
mrs a infection rates and blood stream
infection rates then was reported in
this paper and looking at universal
surveillance i'll talk about this
universal decolonization i'll talk about
this a little bit more later but it's
not only important
you're reading an article to look at the
improvement but also to look at final
outcomes and compare that to your own
data because the studies that are done
in settings where there is very high
rates of disease you may see a reduction
but it may not be as lower reduction as
you as you desire so comparing the data
in the universal decolonisation paper to
our own North Shore results and new
england journal of medicine nejm is the
universal surveillance NS is our Shura
surveillance looking at where we do
targeted decolonisation or targeted
isolation of patients but only those
that are positive for mrs a you can see
that we looked at almost almost fifty
percent of a number of patients 55
patient thousand patient days compared
to 100 1000 and the New England Journal
was no screening but decolonizing
everyone we were screening everyone are
only isolating positives the rate of mrs
a clinical isolates was about seven fold
higher with universal decolonisation
all-cause bacteremia was more than
threefold higher and the rate of mrs a
bacteremia with the universal
decolonization was more than 25 fold
higher and our costs were actually left
so it's important especially when you
have very detailed information given in
publications it's excellent opportunity
to compare what your rates are what your
costs are and what your patient outcomes
are using their kind of data or their
published data in order to decide what
path you should take or you'd like to
take in improving patient outcome for
your own individual patients there's one
last paper on chlorhexidine bathing in
the healthcare associated infection
published this year again from a
well-respected paper the Journal of
American Medical Association
and this is a one-year cluster
randomized crossover trial and five
adult intensive care units primary
outcomes for a central line associated
bloodstream infection Catherine a tract
infection of aryl ventilator-associated
pneumonia and cluster um difficile
infections secondary outcomes are over
overall on multi drug resistant organism
clinical cultures and bloodstream
infections and the intervention group
the chlorhexidine bathing group had no
difference in any of the primary or
secondary outcomes so it is important as
I said have said already and will say
again yeah whatever intervention that
you introduced to monitor outcomes and
make sure that you're having an impact
and if you're not having an impact and
you need to lower your infection rates
than to try something else the big
question comes can we afford mrs a
control and this is important we can't
do things that are not sustainable in
our in our healthcare organizations and
several papers have looked at this now
this is a one from earlier this year
looking at the benefit of Mr esic cost
and control comparing chromogenic auger
with polymerase chain reaction and they
were using literature estimates of cost
to look at intervention costs they
looked at disease reduction and costs
averted and I think if you look at the
gain or loss whether there was financial
gain or loss in this particular study
they were losing money on both chrome
auger and pcr screening the most
expensive intervention you if you will
introduce is one that costs money and
does is not successful it's likely that
chromogenic auger will fail in most
acute care settings because it takes too
long to get the results out in order to
have an impact on isolating mrs a
patient's quickly enough both the
sensitivity of chrome augers less than
that apiece
are in the time turnaround time is
longer but even though you might have
had success with pcr in this particular
model you can see it was much more
costly cost nearly a half a million
dollars for 955 colonized patients and
that's per 10,000 admissions and chrome
augur was about half the cost but again
putting in your own cost data is helpful
and so we when we first started our
program we looked very conservative
model to estimate our health care costs
a of mrs a infection and what i mean by
that is we looked at who got mrs a
healthcare-associated infections in our
in our organization and it occurred in
patients that had a mean like this day
of eight days or greater so we took in
the control population anybody that
wasn't in the hospital for eight days
and remove them from the control
population and then compared patients
with similar procedures similar
comorbidities and matching as best we
could with mrs an infection without de
marsay infection you can see from this
slide they're just developing an Mrs a
nosocomial infection added twenty four
thousand dollars because the cost of
care if you look over to the right the
mean profit loss was about half of that
23,000 and that is because our insurance
companies which is mainly Medicare paid
for half of the excess loss and we we
had to cover the other half so basically
healthcare the health care system lost
about twenty four thousand dollars in
our in our patients who developed an Mrs
a infection and when you plug these
numbers into this particular formula
that was used in this paper and so our
numbers are now what's in the PCR column
you can see the intervention costs are
about the same but the cost of verted
are considerably different when you
actually have a conservative model of
what mrs a
expense is to healthcare and we had a
gain in the economics we had a
successful program and you can see the
cost benefit for 10,000 admissions was
1.5 million dollars so i think if you if
you look at your own data it's possible
to be careful beats it's possible to
carefully decide what pathway to take in
your own healthcare system another
outcome look at of economics for mrs a
testing this looks for 10,000 admissions
and this is look using the same
universal decolonization data that we've
discussed earlier this was published a
little little earlier into 2014 looking
at thousands admissions and the targeted
surveillance and then isolation or
decolonization is in the middle middle
column Universal decolonization on the
right and they included data on the
prevalence the number decolonized number
of days in isolation cost of testing
room entries per day that's important
because that is what will generate your
overall isolation cost and cost of
isolation you can see that in the model
here that the cost of targeted testing
active surveillance testing and then
targeted surveillance or targeted
decolonisation or isolation was more
expensive than universal decolonisation
but if you plug our numbers into it in
our own Hospital we don't have as many
room entries per day we actually now
only test half of our patients and I'll
talk about that in a minute and plugging
our data into the same model that they
use the cost of targeted isolation and
decolonization is actually less than
universal so again it's important when
you have well detailed papers putting
your own numbers take the time to go
through it and see what's best for your
healthcare organization everyone agrees
that the cost of disease always the cost
of
prevention so we just need to how to
decide how to best prevent disease
medical and economic outcome this is
another important summary to look at and
report to your administration when
you're doing this so we've just
summarized their first ten years of
experience with our own program we've
prevented a little over 1000 and
infections had a medical expense
reduction of tetanus on 20 million
dollars 10 million net benefit to our
hospital and avoided 180 deaths or 18
deaths per year based on disease rates
published by the CDC and mortality and
bases mrs a disease so you you can I
think continue to generate
organizational support if you provide
these kinds of numbers to your
administration what are factors that
influence cost and I think we do have to
pay for attention to this in the
laboratory and one of the main factors
that influences your cost of testing is
specificity and specificity difference
of these four different ways of testing
that we published out earlier this year
is in the far left column and this table
generates the cost of the entire program
and you can see from this that even if
you have a test that is less expensive
so the bottom test ten dollars less
expensive than the second test if you
have only a five percent specificity
difference it makes your overall cost of
testing more expensive so we have to pay
attention not only to the manufacturer's
suggested retail price or test costs but
we also have to have to pay attention to
the specificity which drives excess
isolation costs and those can be very
expensive so once a population is tested
and you understand that you can actually
predict quite well who is likely to have
mrs a on admission and reduce the amount
of your number
patients that are tested on admission
and this is another of my colleagues I
robo check did this for us and built a
model predicting on predicting who
needed to be testing tested we validated
that and we wanted to capture ninety
percent of the likely patients who are
positive to be when they're admitted and
by by generating this plot we could see
that we only have to test fifty percent
of the patients on admission and I think
it's important to remember that for
preventable infectious diseases testing
costs decline over time as the disease
goes away and so right right now our
electronic health record still screams
everyone where likelihood of mrs an
infection but we only test fifty percent
and that captures the ninety percent
that are most likely to have mrs a
colonization and this is a another
summary from Illinois Illinois publishes
publicly the mrs a healthcare associated
bloodstream infection rates and we're in
the hospital in the middle here you can
see that our rates compared to other
chicago area hospitals are seven to
fifteen times lower so when this data is
available patients can look at it and
that to make some decisions as to where
they want to go based on what they see
as the safety of the environment so what
can you do in your own hospital now I
think you can look at whether or not you
have an Mrs a bloodstream infection rate
that's too high you can calculate it you
look at from the laboratory the number
of persons that have a positive blood
stream infection whenever I saved more
than two days after admission calculate
the annual patient days and you can
calculate your annual mrs a bloodstream
infection rate we would suggest it
should be less than 24 hundred thousand
patient days if you look at your all of
your mrs a clinical infections culture
results that should be less than five or
ten thousand
patient days so these are quite easy
things to do in your own hospital and I
would encourage you to do that and look
at how high your rates are determined if
you have to do anything beyond what's
already being done next I want to talk a
little bit about Clostridium difficile
infection and the pathogenesis of
clustering difficile infection really
hasn't changed our understanding in 1998
through the most recent review in 2015
patients receive antibiotics they are
they acquire Clostridium difficile and
they get disease from toxins a and B are
the two main toxins that's the official
makes and it does appear from recent
work that toxin b is the major virulence
factor for c difficile and most of the
most of molecular tests focus on toxin b
as the target which is the appropriate
toxin to look at because that is the
cytotoxic as well as the major very
large cotton nationally it looks like
Clostridium difficile is continuing to
go up and projected to go up in the
United States which is opposite the
casen in Europe this is the English data
where rates have gone down some of this
may be driven by definitions of disease
and how disease is measured in the the
various countries but also I think it's
for the u.s. it's important and
imperative that we continue to look at
what's happening with trust rating
difficile epidemiology so that we are
able to contain it Clostridium difficile
infection is a disease by and large of
elderly and this this graph shows the
depicts that very nicely from data from
two thousand or two thousand nine where
the highest disease is in the older
patient and what's extremely concerning
is that the mortality rate has
apparently risen
considerably since in the decade of the
first decade of the 21st century going
from rates of around three percent that
were really the norm for many many years
around nineteen ninety nine eight and
two thousand up to now twenty percent or
more in some reports and this suggests
not only is there more c difficile
disease but its its more virulent in our
population and this is just a national
summary national mortality and cost
again that the rates of mortality have
risen and the estimated costs are six to
nine thousand dollars per year with
considerable overall costs in the united
states exceeding 1 billion dollars so
another another society has made some
testing guidelines for clustering
difficile infection and the most recent
published ones that i've seen for the US
are from the american journal of
gastroenterology and recommending that
the nucleic acid amplification tests are
superior to the enzyme immunoassays and
some of the glutamate dehydrogenase
screening tests can be used in a two or
three step screening LG algorithm but
you will lose sensitivity when you're
doing this and again you can look at
your own laboratory what kind of testing
is being done enzyme immunoassay is a
standalone test is not very frequently
used in the united states anymore it's
going to be mainly bc r or an algorithm
using pcr testing that are used in the
u.s. courting the most recent data so
what kind of laboratory provide i think
what's important is that the laboratory
can provide rep reliable detection of
toxin producing c difficile but we can't
really determine whether the patient has
the difficile infection or now that has
to be a combination of a reliable test
for oxygen across stadium difficile
along with
the appropriate clinical setting that
has to come from our clinical colleagues
taking care of the patients directly
these are the current testing options
and I just put this in your um a summary
on how often to test fit dr. Robo check
and I published a few years ago but it
does lift on the far right hand side the
manufacturer's suggested retail cost of
these various tests and you can see that
they are relatively comparable and that
that choosing the best test should not
be prohibited by the by the cost of this
particular passing several years ago we
started looking as well as others at the
sensitivity of various tests and that's
what's highlighted on this slide where
we're looking at the sensitivity of PCR
compared to enzyme immunoassay and in
2007 we found that pcr could have a
sensitivity over ninety three percent
enzyme immunoassay at the time was
seventy-three percent and as i'll show
you them its subsequent slides this has
gotten worse again highlighting that the
cost of these tests can be fairly
similar as well as the hands down time
especially for enzyme immunoassay and
real-time pcr very very little hands-on
time for the laboratory this is a large
study from that eastwood published in
2009 and again looking at the
sensitivity of various assays for
detection of of potential cost ranges of
co-infection what i want to highlight
here is the glutamate dehydrogenase SAR
gdh which is a component of the cell
wall of clostridium difficile and what
i'm highlighting here is that the
sensitivity will vary depending on the
gold standard so when their gold
standard was tissue culture cytotoxicity
the sensitivity was over ninety percent
one of those culture it was under
ninety percent and all of this makes a
major impact in the sensitivity of the
two step algorithms where gdh is often
the first step this is another study
from Novak week weekly published in 2010
looking at very similar things just
wanted to highlight the sensitivity
again and here EIA is down below sixty
percent sensitivity and this PCR tests
which happened to be the gene Xpert was
over ninety four percent so as we move
forward the sensitivity of the eia seems
to be getting worse and worse this is
another study that we published looking
at a thousand non forum stools again
testing multiple assays and we had 100
and 146 that were considered true
positives by reviewing of the chart and
we used this gold standard enrich
toxigenic culture so both direct plating
to auger as well as to broth and then
plating again to auger and again
highlighting the sensitivity of the
various tests EIA s or under 40 are
under fifty percent we want to highlight
the g2g DHS which is in them are in the
middle katie seven and eighty-four
percent and the pcrs or the commercial
PCR this happened to be to be the genome
genome cows was ninety-five percent so
when we're looking at a sensitive method
for detection of clustered and difficile
de the gdh tensor has generally been
found to be under ninety percent
sensitivity and then we started looking
at a kind of all the tests together and
this is a nice review of clinical micro
reviews from two years ago again coming
up with EIA is lacking sensitivity and
detection of c difficile and clinical
specimens alone does not equate with
disease why is
hey so inferior pred 10 / published nice
paper a few years ago showing that EIA
lacks specifics sensitivity for some of
the rainbow types so as c difficile
changes we may see more and more
reduction in eaa so i want to go over
some of this relatively quickly so we
have tenders for questions at the end
the building the case for correct
correct testing and the issue becomes
you need a sensitive test this looks at
what happens when you just repeat the
same test and with a sensitivity of eia
only 73 percentage of five repeat tests
to actually find all 100 total true
positives but by then you had 107 false
positives EIA there therefore actually
you can't really use and repeat just do
repeat testing to try to find all the
positives because you'll end up with a
lot of false positives the real-time pcr
does matter but even with taking two
repeats to find all of true positives
you still end up with a significant
number of false positives and the impact
of rapid testing this is looking at the
cytotoxic and assay compared to PCR
compared to a two-step essay and what
the impact was basically the right more
rapid your test is the shorter your
patients require to be treated and
empiric therapy decreases because your
results are back more quickly what we're
starting to look at here is the impact
of how you test what what difference to
make what test you're using do you get
too many false positives true positives
and this is looking at another study
where they come from reported
complications occurring within 30 days
and they were specifically looking at
what what combinations of tests gave you
complications in trying to decide what
tests actually we're really telling you
who had clustering difficile infection
and who might be colonized this study
also looked at the time to detection of
an outbreak and in this study the this
slide the lower line graph shows EIA and
the incidence of c difficile infection
and you can see that it took longer to
crush the threshold of 0 point 9 for
10,000 patient days of infections which
was the was the government imposed
threshold so you actually when you did
at eaa testing it looked like your
hospital is doing better but eventually
got up to the high rates of disease and
didn't recognize there was a problem as
early and this is another study this is
looking at their data from pc r+ only
and that would be EA a negative pcr
positive and yeah a and cytotoxicity
both positive and the differences you
can see that there were more there was a
higher mortality in patients that had
both pcr and EA a positive and there
were more readmissions and more
complications but it wasn't totally
negative in the PCR only and this is an
early suggestion that the PCR positive
only did have disease but maybe just not
as severe disease this is a study out of
England looking at the same thing
looking at gdh toxin and toxin gene
tests and they separated into three
groups those that were cytotoxin
positive and culture positive cytotoxins
negative and culture positive or both
and they had a large number of samples
over 8,000 and this is their data and
what you can see here is that death
occurred most frequently in the all test
positive versus all tests negative but
the patients that were either cytotoxin
negative of culture positive or
cytotoxins negative and nap or PCR
positive were intermediate in the
findings and the only mortality
difference was for all test positive and
all because negative again suggesting
that the patients with more severe
disease we had all of their tests
positive but you still have true true
patients with Clostridium difficile
infections that are PCR positive or
culture positive only and
nice not cytotoxin positive this is a
final study looking at this particular
same question and all-cause mortality in
the second bullet was higher in the eia
positive and pcr positive and for the
eia positive and area a negative and pcr
positive but it still did occur
persistent diarrhea was also worse in
that in the all test positive so EA a
positive strongly predicted death and
diarrhea but pcr positive was still
associated with disease so can the can
the specimen prevalence really help you
as a specimen is a quality measure and
we look at this in particular to see
what your levels of positivity should be
in the laboratory for pcr and EIA and it
looks like your PCR positive rate should
be about twice that when you're you were
having what you have we're using EIA and
pcr positive prevalence should be
monitored if you're if if that's not as
a satisfactory should look at things
cliff McDonald from the CDC and I did a
program for State Health Department and
this was our suggestion that when you're
using EIA the the prevalence of positive
test should be ten to fifteen percent
when pcr should be fifteen to twenty
percent more and if not look to see that
your lab is rejecting form schools and
also make sure that your clinicians are
ordering tests only on those patients
that truly have the right setting
frustrating difficile infection and this
is looking at our own data again you can
see when in the left one we're using EIA
testing our positive test prevalence of
seven and a half percent and we've
switched to PCR it was sixteen point
seven percent economic analyses have
been done looking at this this is the
first large as
a comprehensive study on this looking by
trader published last year and
undemanding tat if the case is that you
missed works were costing more than five
thousand dollars or they resulted in two
or more transmission so that the
question being asked here is if you if
you do a slower test other than a real
time pcr assay does that mean you're
going to have more spread in your
hospital and more disease and eventually
more cost to your health care system by
missing these tests and this particular
paper seemed to say yes this is another
paper that was just published earlier
this year suggesting the two-step
algorithm with superior but they used a
glutamate dehydrogenase sensitivity of
about ninety four percent which meant
you don't need miss many patients so if
you use a sensitivity in the 80s that
will change these results so again in
reading these articles it's very
important to know what numbers go into
the models that are being developed so
testing options financial testing
options this is a way of figuring out
can you afford to do see pcr c difficile
testing and we in the US it's typical
for putting for patients to go into
isolation as a precaution when a c
difficile test is ordered and we
discussed this with our infection
control program and when we were able to
offer PCR testing for c difficile 24
hours a day seven days a week they were
willing to wait until the patients had a
positive test with going into isolation
so by doing this we had eighty eight
percent of the tests were negative
patients did not need to go into
isolation and the bottom line was by
saving all the isolation costs we could
spend up to forty three dollars and
sixty-three cents per assay and still
come out even or ahead in costs by doing
a PCR test and avoid all of the
the unnecessary expenses and patient and
convenience and healthcare worker
inconvenience of putting people into
isolation so for mrs a you're really
using pcr to try to get a rapid result
back rapidly isolate patients and avoid
disease and justify the cost that way
for clostridium difficile infection
you're avoiding unnecessary isolation
cost which is can be a very large
expense and can justify your test costs
in that way pattern of an outbreak just
briefly c difficile tends to be endemic
at low levels and that's demonstrated on
this slide when when a new strain comes
into your healthcare setting you may
have outbreaks and the sooner you
recognizes the better off you are so you
can control the outbreak and it will go
away very interesting paper published
that you're looking at EIA and pcr
detection of outbreaks and as you can
see that from this paper the pcr
detected more healthcare associated
infections and actually told them that
they were having a but they were above a
threshold and having an outbreak where's
the eaa if they have been using that
would not have found or even detected
the outbreak in and that alerted them to
the problem so it does suggest that
sensitive testing can be useful both for
detecting patients all patients with
cluster and business no infection as
well as for detecting outbreaks briefly
I just want to finish with this slide
these two slides showing that when you
have a high level disease and the second
third column from the left is our
healthcare associated CDI raised for our
hospitals our four hospitals in 2012 we
wanted to get the rates down we actually
tried four different interventions in
our four hospitals and then combine them
all in 2014 and by doing so we reduced
our c difficile infection rates to very
very low levels to six per 10,000
patient days which equates to 2.4 cases
per thousand patients and this is just a
graph of this and if you look at the
curves the two curves where we were
doing all interventions and where we
were monitoring cleaning with
environmental services and using Glo
germ on the wall and then then
reclaiming the room if it wasn't
satisfactory clean clean those two
interventions both reduce disease
whereas enhancing hand hygiene and
changing to a sports I have a cleaner
did not so what the takeaway is from
this is to make sure that you decide
what intervention you want to do and
monitor the outcome and then change what
you're doing if you're not having the
desired impact so reducing c difficile
infections benefits isolation of expense
mail from malpractice claims impact hand
hygiene or impacts detection to improve
control and in the u.s. it will help you
avoid Medicare's or what's called by CMS
fines which are conditional condition of
participation and imported for hospitals
to avoid you can calculate your own
rates you can look at again the number
of persons in the hospital for two or
three days after admission with one year
with onset of clustered and difficile
infection and the number of annual
patients and if you're if you're
clustering difficile infection rate is
greater than 5,000 admissions you really
look should look at your health care
practices and do what you can to lower
those rates so to summarize molecular
testing can play a critical role in
controlling healthcare associated
infections financial implications on how
you justify this will vary with disease
the role of rapid Diagnostics are
revolutionising our practice and
treatment of healthcare-associated
infections and we need to work closely
with innovative industries as well as
government to achieve the final goal of
improving patient care and my own
personal feeling is crucial for the
laboratory to be visible to our quality
of
risk management partners so the benefits
that are accruing to our organization
are recognized and we're given the
necessary support thank you very much
i'll try to answer any questions
thank you dr. Peterson correct excellent
presentation it's now time for QA before
we get started electrode in my everyone
now to submit their QA comments and
questions just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and click on stand
or get through as many questions as we
have time for our first question comes
from Elizabeth McDaniels her question is
what is the possibility of comparing
quantities as she did in stool two
quantities of usual flora to determine
presence or absence of infection with
positive c diff test I think that's a
wonderful question it's difficult with
using just regular culture because
trying to define what normal or usual
flora is using routine clinical
microbiology cultures is probably not
doable this is being carefully looked at
using deep sequencing as part of the
gastrointestinal microbiome project and
clearly there are patterns of stool that
are abnormal that you see with sea
dificil and then they return to the more
normal picture or pattern when c
difficile infection resolved so I that
this is being looked at and right now it
does appear that there are a few
organisms that are critical to
maintaining a healthy flora to avoid c
difficile infection but that it's
probably content for another
presentation two or three years from now
our next question is from Jacques
Netherland tilt tilt country memorial
hospital lab do you have any data
reflecting the newer PCR testing for sea
dip including the limousine and amp
review
we haven't used those in our own
laboratory and basically what I would
recommend for anybody look looking at
this is to take if you want to really
compare from either eat compare have
identical apples to apples of you all
identical data either compare what's in
the package inserts or compare with what
is in the published literature for the
various assays and look specifically at
sensitivity and specificity trying to
get over ninety-five percent sensitivity
and over ninety eight percent
specificity it's a challenge you you
most of the molecular tests have that
test performance but if it's if there's
a if there's a variation in when you're
comparing you the package inserts or
what's in the published literature then
you have to take that into consideration
depending on what sa you're using the as
I mentioned in the talk that sa
performance is really predicated on what
the gold standard is used and for tests
in the United States right now the Food
and Drug Administration is requiring an
enriched culture for clostridium
difficile and for mr sa sa development
so what this means is that the suspense
played it on regular usually selective
auger and then also put into broth
incubated usually overnight and then put
into the more selective auger looking
for the organism in question thank you
next question from Lillian Lillian J
Gomez regarding the assessment of
clinical relevance of a positive
molecular tests for CDI and outcomes in
other words death rates did the patients
receive the same therapeutic approaches
had the same comorbidities that's
another excellent question and generally
you don't get that level of granularity
in the
LT in the multicenter trials so so the
short answer that is no we don't really
know that data and so you'd like to look
at studies that are are more broad we
just we've just finished a large study
of our own where each patient was that
was interviewed and tried to determine
clinically whether there's a c difficile
infection present very it's very very
complex and unfortunately c difficile
has a spectrum of disease from mild to
very severe patients in the hospital are
often on laxatives sums are stool
softeners some are receiving intro
feedings and so you have a lot a lot of
diarrhea excuse me that isn't well
defined and ideally we would have that
kind of data but for most of the
published literature it's not existed
thank you dr. Peter said I just give it
one more minute for anyone else who
might have a question or comment but if
you have another question for dr.
Peterson please please send it in now if
there are no more questions I had wiped
like once again to thank dr. Peterson
first presentation dr. Peterson do you
have any final comments you'd like to
make just one I saw there was one last
question I came in on point-of-care
testing and I think this will be the
next next revolution if you will in the
microbiology revolution we've all been
going through for the last ten years
what's very interesting as assays become
more miniaturized they get faster and so
some of the point-of-care assays
molecular tests still real real time PCR
assays Darce based assays will provide
answers in 20 or 30 minutes with the
same test performance as the traditional
real time pcr so I think that's the next
thing to keep an eye out for again look
at the quality of the data that's being
that's being accepted for for release of
these assays by the regulatory agencies
they don't always have the same
reviewers and sometimes the quality of
the data isn't as good for all of the
test product so it's important for the
medical and clinical microbiologist
those of us that are deciding what tests
to use to not only look at the summary
data in the approvals but also look at
how the statistics were perform how leg
large the datasets are and whether we
make whether we agree with the
conclusions that are in the package
inserts okay excuse me um well once
again dr. Peterson I'd like to thank you
again for your presentation today and
I'd like to give special thanks to the
audience as well as our sponsor roche
diagnostics for making it possible to
bring you this presentation before we
end today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through februari
third 2016 you will receive an email
from us alerting you when it's available
on demand and posted on Leopards com
you're welcome to form this announcement
to any colleagues for able to join us
today thanks for logging on and
participating in today's broadcast until
next time goodbye and thank you thank
you